Let's look into whether debt
financing your business is the right
option for you.
We'll first define debt financing,
then hear about the benefits and
downsides of choosing this option.
So first, what is it?
Debt financing is basically any form of
loan you could get to help start your
business.
Banks, lenders, or
any other source of income that you
need to pay back is all a form of debt.
When using debt financing as an option,
the main thing to consider is that
you'll be paying back the loans you
get over an extended period of time.
Each payment will include
a principal plus interest.
The principal payment is the amount
that will go towards paying
the original loan amount.
The interest charge will vary
depending on the loan, but
this is the amount you owe on top of
the principal payment as a fee for
borrowing money from your lender.
There are a few benefits and downsides
to be aware of before considering
debt financing for your business.
So first, what are some of the benefits?
Let's overview three of them,
ownership, taxes, and interest rates.
First ownership, when borrowing money
from a bank or any other lender for
your business, you have the same
agreement as with any other loan.
You're agreeing to make your
payments on time, and that's it.
From there, you can make whatever
decisions you want about your business,
and the lender stays out of the way.
This let's you get the money you need,
while maintaining full
ownership of your business.
Next, taxes.
When you get a loan for your business,
the payments you make are considered
tax deductible business expenses.
Tax laws vary widely based
on where you live and
may also be impacted by where you
choose to incorporate your business.
This is a great way to minimize
the cost of any loan you accept.
Just be sure to diligently
track your expenses or
get an accountant to make sure you're
getting the returns you should be.
And finally, you can get lower interest
rates for your business loans.
Look through any options you may have,
and choose the one that's best for
your business.
This is a big decision.
This can get pretty complicated, so
I suggest you consult with an accountant
before making any major decisions
like this for your startup.
While there are some benefits to
debt financing, it's important to
understand some of the potential
downsides to choosing this option.
Let's overview three major downsides,
repayment, unaffordable rates, and
credit rating.
First, repayment, when you take a loan,
you don't have to give up any control,
but you will need to continue making
payments, possibly for a very long time.
If your business doesn't work out, and
you aren't making profits to help make
these payments,
your lender still wants their money.
Next, unaffordable rates,
after considering your tax
deductions and discounts,
you might still be getting a pretty
high interest rate from your lender.
It's tough enough to run a business
without having to worry about making
an extra 20% interest on
top of your other expenses.
And finally,
be careful about your credit rating.
If you choose to take out a personal
loan, it may affect your credit score.
Having extra marks on your credit score
makes you a bigger risk to your lender,
and you'll end up paying for
that at even higher interest rates.
One option to overcome this downside
is to obtain a business loan.
It is more difficult due
to logistical issues, but
the advantage is that it won't
affect your personal credit score.
While debt financing is possible,
it's a really tough way to go and
could be pretty devastating if
things don't go according to plan.
It's best to validate the success of
your product by seeking investment or
by operating a business with personal
expenses you can afford to lose.
If you decide debt
financing is right for
you, be very careful about how you plan
your business and do plenty of research.